you getting this part is one of those
kind of hollywood fairy tale things
so take us back you're i think you're
16. you're in high school yeah what
happened
literally so like i'm sitting here right
now and i'm like what happened
uh oh yeah 16 years old i got sent a
tweet from cindy tolan our incredible
casting director uh she was looking for
four people she was looking for maria
anita bernardo and tony and she was
looking for latinas age 15 to 25 and i
was like that's me uh but my friend
mckenna sent it to me and said thank me
when you're famous and i laughed my ass
off at that but then i thought i just
played the role on stage maybe maybe you
know
i was one out of 30 000 people
who auditioned for it and i auditioned i
auditioned for a year you auditioned for
a year with nine calls no job's worth
that honey all right
no job's worth it this one was yeah and
it was it was nine times and i think
don't think i met steven until six
months into the process and then i had
six months more to go it was screen
tests and chemistry tests and more and
more and then there was like a period of
time of silence where i was like well i
didn't get that and i
started moving on to other things and
then they they called me uh kind of late
december of 2018 and they said we want
you to come in one last time
and when i got it i screamed holy
really loud
and then i just started crying saying
this has been the longest year of my
life
and uh i i to this day i mean one out of
30 000 you say what are the odds and
you're like one out of 30
and i love that when you get the part
you then ask steven spielberg if it's
okay to do something i asked steven
spielberg
if i could still do my senior year
musical which was shrek the musical
you laughed princess fiona princesses
fiona over here it's fantastic musical
janine tasori who actually worked on
west side story with us composed the
music for shrek and i was like
but steven looked at me and he was like
i produced the original shrek of course
you could do shirts
and uh and i ended up doing it getting
painted green i looked like i had
jaundice for like three weeks after i
did this show yeah i think we've got a
picture of you
there you are
[Applause]
that same girl
that same girl went on to sing i feel
pretty with her whole
on chest
movie screen
[Music]